هزه ارضيه في هاتايا التركيه اكملت تدمير
ما تضرر من مبان في الزلزال الاول قوتها
كانت 6.3 على سلم
سته الاف هزه ارضيه واكثر خلال الاسبوعين
الماضيين ضربت جنوبيه تركيا وشماليه سوريا
منذ اول زلزالين في السادس من فبراير
الحالي
كل الارتدادات التي ضربت تركيا وسوريا
والبلدان القريبه كانت عند الاربع درجات
على سلم ريختار الا ان زلزال امس فاق
السته درجات الامر الذي اثار تساؤلات حول
ماهيته هل هي هزه ارتداديه ام انه زلزال
اخر علميا حسب هيئه المسح الجيولوجي
الامريكيه تكون الهزات الارتداديه اقل قوه
من الزلزال الرئيسي وتتناقص تدريجيا الى
ان تنتهي هذا يدل ان المنطقه المنكوبه هي
في ذروه النشاط الزلزالي
الهيئه الامريكيه اكدت ان الزلزال الاول
في غاز عنتاب تسبب في كسر على الفالق
الزلزالي طوله يصل الى 350 كيلومترا
ويتطلب هذا النوع من الكسور الى وقت طويل
لكي يلتئم وبالتالي يجب توقع حدوث هزات
اخرى
الاخبار الكاذبه والتنبؤات غير العلميه
التي انتشرت عبر وسائل التواصل اثارت ضجه
وزادت مخاوف الجمهور لكن هيئه المسح
الجيولوجي الامريكيه نفت بشكل قاطع قدره
التنبؤ بالزلازل الكبيره
انس النماسي العربيه